[Musique]
ils vous voient quand vous dormez
il sent quand vous êtes s'éveiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais si vous avez été sages arrête
les enfants ne sont pas idiots ils
savent comment ça marche
pardon père noël la caméra
c'est le père noël en chair et en os
une seule guitare
[Musique]
vous ressemblez pas au père noël
les panneaux de pub ou rage ou 40 kilos
noël est en danger
pour y arriver si on s'y met tous
ensemble
j'en ai vu de choses étranges dans ma
vie mais ça raconte voir ce qui arrivera
ensuite
moi
si jamais tu rencontres la mère noël un
jour évite évite de lui raconter ça
[Musique]
vous voulez vous retrouver sur la liste
des enfants pas sages
on est d'accord alors on se remet au
boulot